so there's been a release of a deleted
scene from the batman which shows off
more of this version of the joker which
was teased at the very end of the actual
film and it's kind of confirmed to me my
initial suspicions that i don't really
want to see more of this joker i mean
the performance was fine all things
considered the dynamic between the
characters wasn't off it was decent but
the more we saw him and we still didn't
really get a really good look at him but
he's got like this
missing clumps of hair and this kind of
diseased look about him you know what he
reminded me more than anything was
jeremiah in season five of gotham and i
really didn't like jeremiah in season
five of gotham i mean part of that was
jerome was so much better but just in
general it doesn't leave me with a
feeling like oh i want more of this guy
i would rather see
this world's take on other on other
villains that we haven't seen before
but then again i was wrong about the
film overall and i ended up liking it so
who knows